[Music]  that's right a newly unearthed deleted  scene from The Devil Wears Prada is  making the rounds and it's got a ship  when do we eat here you damn bartender  won't even serve in the scene and  hathaways Andy Steves Miranda from being  humiliated by her over-served husband  why don't you get me another drink  you'd have to listen to you wouldn't he  little guy oh I have just been dying to  ask you if it's true that John here used  to ghostwrite the editors page of my  fans on Twitter were quick to point out  the tender moment is so out of character  for the icy-cold Miranda Priestly  here's what made the final cut its  ambassador Franklin and that's the woman  that he left his wife Rebecca the cut  scene would have really changed the  entire movie right  please bore someone else with your  questions  [Music]